[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
guten abend und willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem mittwoch
norbert lehmann ist auch wieder dabei
für den sport frank schindler familie
und wir haben unter anderem diese themen
für sie
will öl-embargo gegen russland eine
wichtige einnahmequelle für putin könnte
schon bald weitgehend versehen
bus und bahn zum schnäppchenpreis wegen
des neuen euro tickets für alle
befürchten verkehrsbetriebe und länder
hohe verluste
und sieg im hexenkessel der fc liverpool
sieht in villarreal ins finale der
champions league ein
[Musik]
wir wollen dass die ukraine diesen krieg
gewinnt sagte eu-kommissionspräsident in
von der leyen deswegen schlägt die
kommission jetzt dieses sechste
sanktionspaket gegen russland vor ein
teil ist der importstopp von russischem
öl der soll in sechs monaten gelten mit
sonderregeln für ungarn und die slowakei
offen ist wie sehr das embargo russland
tatsächlich schwächen würde und ob die
mitgliedsstaaten zustimmen florian
neumann berichtet noch bis kurz vor
ihrem auftritt hatten sie gerungen wie
die kommission kritische eu
mitgliedstaaten überzeugt von einer
sanktion die europa auch selbst schadet
ein embargo auf russisches öl
letzte klar machen wir uns nichts vor
das wird nicht einfach einige
mitgliedstaaten hängen erheblich von
russischem öl ab aber wir müssen es
einfach tun
noch importiert europa russisches öl im
wert von 450 millionen euro pro tag und
finanziert damit auch putins kriegskasse
nach dem vorschlag der kommission aber
nicht mehr lange in sechs monaten wenn
man kein rohöl mehr importieren in acht
monaten keine ölprodukte eine
verlängerung soll es geben für ungarn
und die slowakei die beiden länder fast
vollständig von russischen öl abhängig
hätten bis ende 2023 zeit fielen im
europaparlament dauert das zu lange
das feld weit hinter dem zurück was
dieses parlament schon vor einem monat
gefordert hat nämlich ein komplettes im
balco auf gas und öl
andere fürchten drastisch steigende
energiepreise auch bei uns und deshalb
brauchen wir jetzt ein europaweiter
energiepreis deckel damit energie armut
effektiv bekämpft werden kann schärfere
sanktionen auch im finanzbereich jetzt
soll auch die größte russische bank
sberbank vom zahlungssystem
ausgeschlossen werden dass die
sanktionen zu einem schnellen kriegsende
führen aber glaubt kaum jemand die
botschaft an putin war von anfang an
sehr klar wenn du eine invasion und
einen krieg in der ukraine auslöst wirst
du ein ganz ganz hohen preis zahlen und
schritt für schritt mit den sanktionen
setzen wir das auch durch noch müssen
alle eu mitgliedstaaten den sanktionen
zustimmen ungarn hat schon vorbehalte
angemeldet
ungarn hat schon vorbehalte florian in
straßburg obwohl die eu dem land schon
entgegenkommt bröckelt da die einigkeit
der europäischen union
ja es wird zumindest schwieriger diese
union zusammenzuhalten denn jetzt so
sagt es ein diplomat kommen eben die
sanktionen die europa auch selbst
wirtschaftlich schaden und zwar mit
durchaus massiv aber trotzdem gibt man
sich hier bei der kommission doch sehr
zuversichtlich dass diese dieses öl
embargo bis ende der woche auch
beschlossen sein wird man ist den beiden
staaten ungarn und der slowakei ja
massiv entgegen gekommen während alle
anderen eu staaten bis ende des dieses
jahres eben auf russisches öl verzichten
sondern gibt man beiden staaten ein
weiteres jahr zeit dass beide jetzt noch
mehr verlangen dass die viele als teil
des üblichen brüsseler machtspiels an
dass sie eben einfach den preis
hochtreiben in 12 nachtsitzungen dann
noch mehr ergattern wollen eine längere
übergangsfrist etwa am ende wird europa
dieser sanktionen eben mit zwei
geschwindigkeiten vorangehen erstmals
also die einigkeit die bröckelt ein
wenig aber man ist bereit diesen preis
zu zahlen um eben überhaupt
voranzukommen bei dieser sanktionen
dankeschön nach straßburg florian
neumann war dass
die folgen dieser sanktionen werden alle
zu spüren bekommen die preise für öl
gingen heute direkt nach oben die an den
tankstellen werden wohl folgen nach
einschätzung von wirtschaftsminister
habeck ist die übergangs ist zwar lang
genug um alternativen zu russischen öl
zu finden dennoch könnte es in
ostdeutschland regional stoppen sagte er
bei der regierungsklausur in meseberg
heike slansky hat mehr tag zwei des
arbeitstreffens der koalition auf
schloss meseberg zurückgezogen in
entspannter atmosphäre thematisch jedoch
überschattet vom krieg in der ukraine
der deutschland und die welt verändert
hat klar ist auch dass aus dieser
veränderung feucht dass putin sich
vollständig verrechnet hat mit seinem
brutalen angriffs krieg gegen die
ukraine denn was er bekommt ist eine
stärkere nato ist die stärkere
organisation von sicherheit auch an den
östlichen staaten des nato gebietes was
er bekommen hat ist eine einige
europäische union die auswirkungen des
krieges steigende energiepreise eine
enorm hohe inflation das geplante öl
embargo wird zu weiteren belastungen
führen die regierung will betroffenen
standorten wie schwedt und leuna helfen
die übergangsfrist ist so ausreichend
lang dass wir alle vorkehrungen treffen
können um alternativen für russisches öl
in deutschland zu schaffen
vorkehrungen treffen heißt nicht dass
sie sich gleich realisieren ein zügiger
bau von flüssiggasterminals soll auch
die abhängigkeit von russischem gas
reduzieren ebenfalls der schnellere
ausbau von erneuerbaren außerdem werden
weitere sanktionen geprüft zum beispiel
ob per gesetz sanktionierte ihr vermögen
offenlegen müssen das wäre ein ganz
neues instrument um die durchsetzung
bestehender sanktionen gegen natürliche
personen gegen juristische personen um
das schlagkräftiger zu machen den druck
auf putin erhöhen gleichzeitig die
ukraine weiter unterstützen und
geflüchtete schneller integrieren themen
auf der kabinettsklausur in unsicheren
zeiten
zum geschehen in der ukraine auch am 70
kriegstag gab es wieder heftige kämpfe
entlang der front zugleich versuchten
helfer weitere zivilisten aus mario pohl
auch aus dem umkämpften stahlwerk dort
nachsah borussia zu bringen russland
griff unterdessen mehrere strategisch
wichtige bahn stationen an eine neue
lemberg das ziel den nachschub an
westlichen waffen abschneiden lena
sünder bruch
feuerwehrleute kämpfen in der nacht
darum die flammen in einem kraftwerk in
lemberg unter kontrolle zu bringen die
stadt nahe der polnischen grenze war
bislang weitgehend verschont geblieben
nun aber versucht russland durch
gezielte luftangriffe mehr denn je die
infrastruktur hier und im ganzen land zu
lähmen offenbar um westliche
waffentransporte zu stoppen ich möchte
darauf hinweisen dass wir jeden nato
transport der mit waffen und nachschub
für die ukrainischen streitkräfte ins
land kommt als legitimes militärisches
ziel betrachten
vom westen in den osten der ukraine nach
mariupol dort bereitet man sich auf eine
weitere evakuierung vor
natürlich werden wir weiterhin alles tun
um alle unsere leute aus mariupol und im
stahlwerk herauszuholen derzeit halten
sich die russischen truppen nicht an die
vereinbarungen sie setzen ihre massiven
angriffe auf das stahlwerk fort
russland dementiert das obwohl us
amerikanische satellitenbilder neue
rauchwolken über dem stahlwerk zeigen
helfer der vereinten nationen kümmern
sich um die mehr als 150 menschen die
gestern von dort in sicherheit gebracht
werden konnten nach mehr als zwei
monaten im bunker sind sie zurück im
tageslicht und es gibt die vermutlich
erste warme mahlzeit seit langem
es war schrecklich von morgens bis
abends wurden wir bombardiert artillerie
raketen luftangriffe die kinder konnten
nicht schlafen haben geweint sie hatten
angst und wir auch
in mariupol harren noch rund 100.000
zivilisten aus sergej und ludmilla sind
zwei davon sie versuchen in den trümmern
ihres hauses zu überleben
meistens bombardieren die russen
hochhäuser
und hier haben sie genau den zweiten
stock getroffen da lebte eine frau jetzt
ist sie dort begraben
die russen hätten ihnen erlaubt in den
süden russlands umzusiedeln erzählt
müller doch das hätten sie abgelehnt und
so lebt das ehepaar wie viele weiter
inmitten der bombardements
katrin eigendorf in kiew gibt es im
moment überhaupt noch verhandlungen
zwischen den kriegsparteien
also interessanterweise das wort
verhandlungen und perspektiven für
verhandlungen fällt hier in kiew relativ
selten bis gar nicht mehr zum jetzigen
stand im moment reden die ukraine hier
und allen voran auch präsident selensky
davon dass sanktionen erhöht werden
müssen dass waffenlieferungen verstärkt
werden müssen man redet auch von
reparationszahlungen mittlerweile für
eine mögliche nachkriegs perspektive
zielinski hat ja gerade noch einmal
öffentlich auf die nachfrage nach
verhandlungen geäußert dass es für ihn
klar hier rote linien gäbe dass er sich
nicht damit abfinden würde dass russland
territorium der ukraine besetzen würde
er würde sich auch nicht auf einen
halbherzigen frieden zu kosten von land
gewinnen für russland ein lassen also
das ist eine ziemlich klare haltung die
die ukraine hier vertritt und das ist
natürlich ganz entgegen den russischen
erwartungen dass sie hier möglicherweise
weiteres land annektieren könnten und
dass vielleicht sagen wir mal die
perspektive land für frieden eine option
wäre die für putin gesichtswahrend
diesen krieg beenden könnte da ist man
in kiew im moment relativ klar und hart
in der haltung dankeschön für diese
einschätzung live aus kiew katrin
eigendorf war das zdf heute live spricht
gleich mit einem mitarbeiter vom roten
kreuz der bei den evakuierungen aus
mario pohl dabei war um 19 uhr 30 in der
zdf- heute- app und auf unseren social
media kanälen
nach bayern für die csu ist es
ausgesprochen unangenehm ihr
generalsekretär stephan mayer musste
seinen hut nehmen weil er einen
journalisten übel beschimpft und bedroht
hat völlig unangemessen und indiskutabel
nannte das heute parteichef söder sprach
aber auch von einer menschlichen
tragödie aus münchen alexander pohl
der rücktritt seines generalsekretärs
und engsten mitarbeiters ist für markus
söder ein politischer gau stephan mayer
hatte einem redakteur der bunten nach
einem bericht über sein privatleben mit
vernichtung gedroht die dabei wohl
gefallenen worte sind in keinster weise
zu akzeptieren
sind völlig unangemessen und auch ein
indiskutabler still in einem artikel
berichtet der reporter manfred
otzelberger von den
familienverhältnissen des csu
generalsekretärs für seinen unehelichen
sohn so heißt es zahlen nicht meyer
sondern dessen vater den unterhalt nach
der veröffentlichung rief mayer bei dem
reporter an er hat herumgepöbelt sofort
gedroht
dass er
er hat die absurde these vertreten sie
haben mein leben zerstört
jetzt vernichte ich sie mit stefan maier
verliert csu-chef söder einen seiner
profiliertesten innenpolitiker die csu
wirkt im jahr vor der wahl verunsichert
in umfragen leicht verbessert aber eine
laut vernehmbare politische botschaft
fehlt die partei wird von ihrer
vergangenheit eingeholt gegen den
ehemaligen verkehrsminister steuer
ermittelt die staatsanwaltschaft und ein
untersuchungsausschuss zu masken affäre
ist in vollem gang die csu ist wichtig
dass wir programmatisch
antworten geben vor allem auf die
landtagswahl die für uns die wichtigste
ist in eineinhalb jahren diese antworten
zu formulieren wäre auch die aufgabe des
neuen generalsekretärs den muss die csu
erst wieder finden bis freitag könnte
eine entscheidung fallen
die staatsanwaltschaft stuttgart hat
gegen baden-württembergs innenminister
strobel von der cdu ein
ermittlungsverfahren eingeleitet wegen
unerlaubter weitergabe von
gerichtsunterlagen
im mittelpunkt steht ein ranghoher
polizist dem sexuelle belästigung einer
kollegin vorgeworfen wird strobl hatte
ein internes rechtsanwalts schreiben in
dieser sache an einen journalisten
weitergegeben
nordirland ist seit fast 100 jahren
gespalten zwischen denen die sich als
teil der republik irland fühlen und
denen die die zugehörigkeit zu
großbritannien verteidigen morgen nun
steht eine richtungswahl in nordirland
an es sind parlamentswahlen und zum
ersten mal könnten die irischen
nationalisten der shinsei stärkste kraft
werden über die möglichen folgen
berichtet ja sie nie allein es liegt
historisches in der luft bei diesen
wahlen in nordirland michelle o neals
parteiisch in fällen könnte die stärkste
im parlament in belfast werden und sie
damit erste ministerin erstmals legen
dann die katholischen republikaner vorn
im land die machtverhältnisse haben sich
verschoben unumkehrbar zu lasten wird
das wohl der bisher führenden
demokratischen unionisten gehen
protestanten die sich eine enge
anbindung an großbritannien wünschen
eine wiedervereinigung irlands wie schön
sie fordert wenn sie strikt ab auch das
so genannte nordirland protokoll ist den
unionisten ein dorn im auge jene klausel
die im brett abkommen de facto eine
zollgrenze zwischen nordirland und dem
rest des königreichs schafft in die
grenze zur republik irland offen zu
halten mauern zwischen den katholischen
und protestantischen stadtteilen in
belfast und kämpferische wandmalereien
zeigen die alten narben des bürgerkriegs
sind nicht gänzlich verheilt die meisten
jungen nordiren haben damit nicht mehr
viel am hut
die politik der vergangenheit die von
den politikern an der macht am leben
gehalten wird kümmert junge leute wenig
ähnlich nüchtern sehen dass nordirlands
unternehmer gerade hat man sich von den
folgen von corona erholt das letzte was
man jetzt gebrauchen kann ist neuerliche
ungewissheit in sachen braig cid es war
absolut kindisch den leuten zu erzählen
dass es keine handelsbarrieren geben
würde dass nordirland protokoll ist die
beste option nachdem vorher alle anderen
möglichkeiten ausgeschlossen wurden
deshalb wird es von den meisten
unternehmern auch befürwortet
der schlichte wunsch nach pragmatischen
lösungen wird gemäßigten kleineren
parteien diesmal viel zulauf bringen und
wird sich zeigen wo die reise hingeht
nach diesen wegweisenden wahlen in
nordirland
einige reiben sich schon voller
vorfreude die hände ab juni soll
hierzulande das neun euro ticket gelten
für insgesamt 27 euro kann man dann drei
monate lang unbegrenzt bus und
regionalbahnen nutzen es sind allerdings
noch einige hürden zu überwinden auch
die bundesländer müssen zustimmen und
die fordern mehr geld kein niklas
details
das neun euro ticket soll impuls zur
verkehrswende und entlastung bei hohen
spritpreisen sein ab juni plant die
bundesregierung daher nahverkehr zum
schnäppchenpreis je neun euro für drei
monate wir wollen einen anreiz zum
energieeinsparen setzen und gleichzeitig
wollen wir auf den öpnv hinweisen und
menschen motivieren in stärker zu nutzen
das brauchen wir um energie zu sparen
unabhängig zu werden von energieimporten
und um unsere klimaschutzziele zu
erreichen doch die länder sehen eine
unterfinanzierung von eineinhalb
milliarden euro bei der einführung des
tickets und fordern den bund auf diese
auszugleichen
wir erwarten dass der bund das
gegenfinanziert das können nicht die
kommunen das können nicht die öpnv
unternehmen das können auch nicht die
länder alles gegenfinanzieren wenn der
bund so einen neuen euro ticket ins
leben ruft dann muss der bund auch dafür
zahlen außerdem muss noch geklärt werden
wie fahrgäste die bisher für abonnement
weit mehr als monatlich 9 euro zahlen
ihr geld zurückbekommen und weiteres
problem schon jetzt gibt es auf
beliebten strecken etwa von berlin an
die ostsee volle bahnsteige und züge
diesen trend könnte das ticket noch
verschärfen bei den regional express
erwarten haben wir jetzt schon der
starke auslastung die gegen 100 prozent
geht und dann wird es dort sicherlich zu
überlastungen kommen die das system so
einfach nicht ran noch wird das ticket
nicht verkauft und bis juni wird die
zeit knapp denn noch wollen bund länder
und verkehrsbetriebe daran festhalten
ökologisch gesehen lebt deutschland von
heute an auf pump umweltschützern
zufolge haben wir alle ressourcen
verbraucht die uns rein rechnerisch für
das ganze jahr zur verfügung stünden das
ist die botschaft des heutigen ehrt
überlastung stars die gründe für den
frühen termin sind unter anderem der
hohe energieverbrauch in deutschland der
hohe co2 ausstoß durch verkehr und
massentierhaltung sowie die
verunreinigung von boden luft und
grundwasser
jetzt freuen wir uns mit jürgen klopp
seine bewohner stehen im champions
league final durch den 3 2 sieg gestern
abend in villarreal klingt nach einer
ziemlich souverän sache was aber gar
nicht die spanier lange zeit auf
augenhöhe führten 2 0 aber da machen wir
es doch noch alles klar binnen zwölf
minuten
emotionales ende des außenseiters aber
mit grandiosen komplimenten
respekt an villarreal stadion team und
coach unglaublich was die hier leisten
sie haben uns komplett unter druck
gesetzt villarreal hat das 0 2 aus dem
hinspiel nach 41 minuten auf im eigenen
hexenkessel aber wann zurück im spiegel
haben erst die tore unter das finale
doch noch wahr gemacht denn dann zeigt
klopp die comeback mentalität seines
teams diaz eingewechselt das 2 zu 2 an
allen toren ist der kolumbianer
beteiligt auch am 3 zu 2 for money als
revanche für die finalniederlage 2018
wünschen sich die reds nun real madrid
muss spiel gestern abend das könnte sich
heute abend wiederholen wenn nämlich
manchester city bei real madrid antritt
das dramatische hinspiel das gewann ja
die mannschaft von pep guardiola knapp
mit 3 2 4 ein englisches finale also
durchaus möglich aber der trainer der
königlichen carlo ancelotti der hat
angekündigt wir werden das ding heute
abend drehen vor 60.000 zuschauern im
bernabeu-stadion
ja und die zusammenfassung der beiden
halbfinal rückspiele mit ausführlichen
analysen und gesprächen heute abend bei
uns im sportstudio champions league um
23 uhr 15 zur basketball-euroleague da
hat bayern münchen das entscheidende
fünfte viertelfinal spiel gegen
barcelona mit 2 1 872 zu 81 verloren und
hat den einzug in die best off verpasst
und in der handball european league da
gab es gestern abend einen heimsieg des
sc magdeburg der bundesliga
tabellenführer gewann das
viertelfinal-rückspiel gegen nord knapp
aber durchaus verdient mit 30 zu 28 und
zieht damit ins finale der besten vier
ein überragender magdeburger michael
tango mit zwölf treffer
das finalturnier dann am letzten
maiwochenende magdeburg ist ja auch der
titelverteidiger und jetzt fehlt noch
motto zu sein sie lauten 3 4 11 31 41 49
superzahl 2 weitere gewinnzahlen finden
sie auf lotto punkt zdf.de und im zdf
text auf seite 5 157
in der nacht klingen schauer und
gewitter ab kommen aber morgen wieder
nur nicht im nord und
nordwestdeutschland details hat gleich
katja honnefer christian sievers begrüßt
sie um viertel vor zehn uhr heute
journal und hier übernimmt morgen mit
risi reden danke für ihr interesse alles
gute ihnen und bis bald auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend auch heute gab es wieder
tages gang wetter also regenschauer und
gewitter die sich im laufe des tages
mehr und mehr ausbreiteten wie zum
beispiel in baden-württemberg und in
bayern auch im saarland in
rheinland-pfalz später dann auch
richtung thüringen und sachsen im
nordwesten bekam sie von regenschauer
und gewitter und eigentlich gar nichts
ab und das bleibt jetzt auch in der
nacht so schauer und gewitter erreichen
aber bis zum frühen morgen hier berlin
und morgen ziehen schauer und gewitter
ostwärts und südostwärts ab am
nachmittag kann es dann hier am rhein
wieder einige schauer geben heute nacht
bleibt ist also zum teil auch mal
trocken zwischen der ostseeküste und der
mosel und die temperaturen sinken auf
zehn grad am oberrhein und in der
uckermark in norddeutschland und auch am
alpenrand geht's auf 3 bis 1 grad runter
da droht also noch einmal bodenfrost die
höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen an der
küste und bei dauerregen im südwesten
nur so bei 13 bis 16 grad sonst werden
15 bis 21 grad erreicht und auch morgen
gibt es wieder schauer und gewitter in
norddeutschland bleibt es dagegen
trocken und am nachmittag kann es vom
rhein her einige schauer geben bei
nordwest wird in den nächsten tagen wird
der samstag der durchwachsenen tag
werden und die temperaturen ändern sich
kaum
guten abend